our series rebuilding america showcases
people and communities that are finding
creative ways to build a better world
one project at a time today we introduce
you to a san francisco couple spreading
flower power on their first date ever
they planted an aloe bush and that was
the seed which inspired a project to
plant native wildflowers in empty lots
across their city
lilia luciano got a lesson in so-called
gorilla gardening which benefits both
nature and us
with pink water guns adapted for sea
dispersal
oh wow this is us behold my street art
it is like street art we met up with
shaliko and phoenix mcgee who've been
leaving their colorful mark on the
streets of san francisco for the last
decade this is so beautiful this is what
happens when the entire seed pack goes
to bloom there's so many colors
it looks like my outfit yeah chalico who
runs a production studio and phoenix a
landscape contractor are seeding a
little joy one planter at a time these
are fun the self-professed gorilla
gardeners plant native wildflowers in
forgotten spaces on streets in vacant
lots even the grounds of the local
police station these are beautiful
they're so hot yeah they're popping off
you bring your shaker like this and the
cops don't say anything
they say thanks for the flowers
what is gorilla gardening we plant
native pollinator seeds and neglected
areas of land
and it's just a nice way to make a
forgotten about space you know full of
full of flowers then you can see the
pollinators all flying around in here
supporting pollinators of course is
beneficial for farming but on the
streets of this concrete jungle
the thrill of a successful seed bombing
is real i think people think it's like
fun and like rebellious and it's getting
them excited about planting with a
quarter of a million followers on tick
tock and over 5 million likes look at
the different seeds in there they've
discovered a whole bunch of passionate
planters on social media and it turns
out sowing these flowers is good for the
soul
we take a break from our computers we
take a walk at sunset and we sow native
seeds on our walks we'll forget that we
sewed a place up with seeds and then
we'll turn a corner three months later
and all of a sudden you'll see all of
the plants california and then a hyper
native bay area mix now the pear is all
about spreading the gospel of the scene
what's been the most rewarding for you
we're speaking at schools and
universities and we met with this troupe
of girl scouts put them in the shaker
and taught them about native wildflowers
they dressed up as bees and we talk
about pollinators and just the benefits
of that and just introducing the next
generation to this and you know sort of
getting them in touch with nature they
were so excited we gave them all little
shakers and then they were running
around with the shakers and dressed as
bees it was really beautiful it all
stems from their desire to brighten up
the city
and bring smiles to their neighbors
faces
do you guys still get very excited every
time we do this every time it never gets
old
what's it feel like to walk by and see
this there's always something that we've
planted blooming so it's just kind of
heartwarming i feel like you can feel it
people call it our magic trick but it's
nature's magic trick we're just helping
it along for cbs mornings i'm lilia
luciano in san francisco